all right so can you just go ahead and  open Thanks  you can get for your cell phone right  now is that you tight right okay I'll  walk you over to my car and I'll explain  everything to you okay I'll explain it  to you in a second okay  this way  watch the book you have a concealed  carry or anything  yes data Florida yeah you ever been  arrested in the state of Florida there  been arrested in general no were you  born Bronks not from upstate New York so  what do you do for work okay like TV  here Oh what do you act in well like you  know like any like film okay you know  any shows right now or anything that's  what do you mean like you're the Fox  okay but he's just gonna search you real  quick yep thank you  Oh  you have a bra or anything on okay all  right just kind of this evening thank  you  watch yourself getting in I'll explain  everything in a second